So, you might be wondering if you
don't have a phone, what you can do.
Well, Android Studio has
actually provided a way for
you to simulate a phone
on your computer.
This simulated phone has a fancy
name called the Android Emulator.
To start the Android Emulator,
go ahead and
go up to the Run button and press Run.
You'll see a small
loading circle down here.
Now, whereas before I told you to select
the Choose a running device radio
button, you're going to want to choose
the Launch emulator radio button.
And here is a drop down of all
the different types of phones
you can simulate.
Right now you should only have one, and
it's most likely going to be a Nexus 5,
which is the type of phone, and API 21
refers to the operating system level.
And x86 refers to a particular
type of hardware configuration.
Anyways, this is the name for
your simulated phone.
And I'm going to go ahead and
click OK to start the phone.
Now after about ten seconds, you should
see a black phone appear on the screen.
You'll also see this window here appear,
which will show any sort of error
messages or
activity messages from the phone.
Okay, so here's my black phone,
and I'm waiting for it to load.
After a moment of that, I'm going to
see this Android loading icon.
After a little bit more time,
you should see this welcome
screen appear on the phone.
To go ahead and start the phone,
swipe up from the bottom.
Now it's trying to simulate an actual
phone, and the first time you load up
an actual phone, you get all
these help icons and dialogues.
I'm going to just click OK.
Now, if all goes well,
your app should appear on your phone.
It didn't for me, so I'm going to
go ahead and try to run it again.
Okay, since the emulator's
already running,
I can see it now under my
Choose running device.
So I'll go ahead and click it.
And I press the OK button.
All right, and it loaded up
my code on my emulated phone.
Now you should know that sometimes these
simulated phones don't always work
correctly the first time.
For example, you might have this issue
that I had the first time when I ran my
simulated phone where it would
just show the black screen or
would just show the Android loading
symbol, and it wouldn't go beyond that.
These are actually fairly common errors
when trying to start a simulated phone.
And one of the reasons that we
suggest using a real device.
That said, for
the most part they're solvable problems.
So, if you are running into
those issues, go ahead and
look at the instructor notes for
how to deal with these situations.
We've provided a link to
a troubleshooting document.
Finally, since I have your attention,
if you're having difficulty with your
simulated phone, sometimes you have
clues in this error output over here.